magic mike the strip co club guy right
yeah that's the stripper movie yeah and
and i was in that tell me about that i
wasn't that i didn't get naked
i didn't get naked none of this came off
it all stayed on what's funny though
when people recognize me
from that movie and then they tell their
friends and they're like he was in magic
mike and then they look at me like
what happened you know was it cgi like
no
i wasn't no i was in it but i wasn't in
you know
[Music]
what's up everybody you guys welcome to
this episode of hot boxing with triple c
aka henry cejudo
and i'm like typing we're here with
fluffy
hey gabe how are you doing man i'm i'm
doing i'm doing good mike i'm doing good
hey when i first came here i knew who
you were but when my son said he knew
who he was and how the hell he's 10
years old
that the hell you know gabriel um
galicious
[Laughter]
normally i correct people but in this
case i'ma let it go my mom dad
help me out there you go
you got i don't see it it's gonna be all
type of [ __ ] you go
you have better than say beauty queen or
some [ __ ] i wouldn't know
you got you said it pretty good how you
doing man i'm doing really really nice
it's an honor to be here at the ranch uh
thank you
i don't know people know that's where
this is at but i just if this is the red
okay
this is where i work here for my fight
this is just where i get prepared
there's also my office
where we do our business and this we
also do hot boxing
it's awesome you have a lot you have
more cameras in here than a sitcom
hey listen these guys just started
paying us man we used to do this for you
that's
free now we get paid for this [ __ ] we
got commercials and [ __ ] right we got
commercials right
let's see listen right i've been here
for long how long
and five years we've been hanging out i
don't know these [ __ ]
you know gabe i don't know these
[ __ ] you don't know nobody
that's in here they
just started like how long y'all been
here
[Laughter]
after six months i know this is dead
gabriel i i find your life
fascinating man i think because i grew
up as a single parent kid too man i
think the success
uh no i'm the last one i'm the last one
he's the youngest last year so he's one
last six
months and there's about 13 roughly
years between my sister and myself she
was like
i grew up an only child you know she was
up and out of the house by the time i
was old enough to want a room
how was your upgrade bringing up like
growing up with that big family
uh you know it was it was pretty awesome
because i was the only one in the house
so i had all the attention from my what
neighborhood what neighborhood what part
of town
uh not too far from here actually uh in
the city of long beach
i was born in san diego grew up in long
beach and you know i still live there
long beach is cool yeah it was a quick
drive over here i was like oh my god
and you have like a farmer boys right i
don't know if you know that they got
farmer boys up the street there's a
mother
yeah i thought they only had those in
the inland empire that's why
what's that dispensary no no no farmer
boys is like a uh
ah god it's like a you know what a
cracker barrel or a famous dave's
kind of a you know more like a breakfast
real hearty breakfasty place and i
always see the commercials on tv
and you always hear farmer boys and i'm
like oh you know and i'm like oh god
that's far that's at least an hour drive
yeah and i'm like that's it no i got
jack in the box across the street
so when you start this stand-up [ __ ] the
best started in your life uh i started
it
yeah yeah what what inspired you to be
oh man you know i'm gonna be 45 so i
mean my my comedy
you know heroes were robin williams paul
rodriguez uh eddie murphy
you know uh eddie murphy raw was a
comedy special i saw and i said oh
you know and not really the uh the comic
you would think would inspire
a comic that works relatively clean you
know but eddie murphy
it was he was a rock star he walked out
on stage he commanded the crowd he did
impressions he told stories and
it was just it was awesome and i said i
want that i don't know
how it's going to happen but i want that
same thing i thought should we let it
fight with bertrand i said i want to be
that
same thing exact thing yeah i didn't
know how i was going to do it but i
wasn't being there
yeah so it almost starts with
inspiration right like it starts with
the imagination that you create in your
mind
yeah you don't know you don't once you
see it it's created in your mind
once you see this is what you want it
started taking on a life of his own
right
and how old were you at this time uh
well i was 10 years old when i saw the
the comedy special and i was just like
yeah by the time i finally did it uh you
know i did a talent show and i did
impressions
on stage yeah you know i didn't know i
was doing comedy i just knew that i was
doing these little
you know 10 year old kid doing
impressions of the president
of you know mickey mouse and all these
other little characters and uh so
to do that and then you know that was
the spark when i actually heard the
reaction from the crowd
as a 10 year old i said that this is
going to happen
and so i joined the speech team when i
was in high school
and then you know a couple years out of
high school i got up on stage one night
and
i've been doing it ever since it had to
be a hit
you know you wouldn't have kept doing it
you know normally your first time you
know me you get some success and that's
when you just can't you get the bug
and you can't stop thinking about it
that's why you know i encourage people
all the time
if you got something that you're really
passionate about freaking do it and all
you know don't look for other people's
approval do it because you want to do it
exactly i did a bunch of movies before
but once i got on stage
that was a totally different animal
you want that feeling all the time i
can't live without it it's that drug on
my
yeah knowing you're able to connect with
so many people at once
it's just like you know out of control
you know when you can make them laugh
you know you can make them sad right now
you know you just can play them it's
just
i can't explain it right this weird it's
strange
yeah because it's uh it's it's man
there's
there's so many aspects meant to just
just life into the journeys
that the co how the how they're almost
very like similar to each other
just in different sports just like mike
like you and him you guys can relate a
lot
listen most athletes and um
entertainers they mostly live in the
same neighborhood they got the same hand
they probably know each other before
they got famous and that's basically
that the same kind of habit
late nights and stuff a lot of women
drinking drugs whatever they have the
same lifestyle so
normally they do associate with each
other who who are your some of
some of your all-time great uh uh
stand-up comedians man
uh sorry uh-huh actually i probably
he let's get us some water because i
imagine
before i actually got into hot boxing
because i was i'm not gonna lie mike i
was nervous i'm like you know what uh
the last time i i
you know did anything uh smoking wise on
in public it was that or that people
knew about was with snoop and it's like
okay you do a show with snoop
of course you know if it happens it
happens nobody's gonna judge on that one
hey
yeah and kind of the same rule applies
here today where i was like well
uh all right i get you know my
mike casually hey take this and i'm like
and i apologize if
you you don't appreciate uh people doing
impressions of you because he's good
no no no no no no
the inner voice became the outer voice
because apparently what you have
to offer is incredible i i was i was
back there and i'm like okay
i guess we're doing this and and next
thing i know i'm halfway through one of
those bats right
and i'm looking at it i'm like yeah okay
this is gonna be
go in a different direction what if i
feel like we're not just gonna talk
about have you ever talked about the
heroes no no it's gonna be like
you know gabe have you ever done shows
before mushrooms no
and today please don't do that to me oh
please don't do that you feel so
light freaking super mario here you go
no no no no shrooms no phone i love
shows
yeah for me but yeah i i feel very
relaxed but at the same time alert
too alert so i'm just you know that was
the diva does it well that's my homework
you heard the oh that's what that was
that's a tv yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
man i imagine as a kid too will you
always fluffy even as a kid
i've always been a big kid yeah you know
that was one of those things i was
always the kid or the husky pants or you
know they got a
they kind of you know here you're uh you
know just
uh they try to put you on a slim fast
diet or you're
yeah i've always i've always been big
well it's always you know weight's
always been an issue
since i was little i imagine like having
like you you have to have a good sense
of humor
like you know what i mean being you know
you want to be a comic because like me
like you know i'm short dude like
i do short jokes you know what i'm
saying so it's almost like as a kid that
you
you always have that sense of humor uh
no man i actually i think i spent a lot
of the time being upset by the jokes and
stuff like that it was kind of like
it turned into a defense mechanism since
i couldn't really
physically do anything about it let me
try to find a way to change the
situation
and take away their power by making fun
or cracking jokes and
being okay with it like whatever you
don't care what you call me you can't
you can't upset me so
you start learning how to find your own
ways of just you know dealing with that
and
humor seemed like the best way yeah so
it's like you know some people say oh
poor guy he's a big guy but you know
it was because of that that something
happened that wound up inspiring me and
motivated me to want to do what i do
yeah because now you now you make money
i mean obviously the character the name
the stand-up it's uh you know it all
revolved around
something that you probably didn't
accept that
you know at the shows i would you know
i'd come out of there
and people would come up to me and
they'd go hey great job fluffy and i'm
like wait wait wait
i did one joke where i said the word i
figured my first name's already
you know i'm sorry the last name is
already a famous name it's been around
for
40 plus years i just got to work on the
gabriel and
people would you know gravitate to the
fluffy thing above
everything and so i hated being called
fluffy but i only had about 10 minutes
of material
and that was like a large chunk of the
material so when you're a new comic you
don't want to give up your jokes easy
eventually i learned to not only accept
it but you know
take it to a place where i just like
yes i own the word i basically own the
word if you put fluffy in on any search
engine i am the number one search for
that word
because i embraced it so many years ago
yeah and learned to brand it
really would you brand into like and i
don't know if i don't know if you are
already
like are you into like to the food
business uh you know what
it's tricky uh i had thought about
opening up a restaurant
two years ago no and it's a good thing i
pulled the plug on this frozen meats
well i'm you know any kind of restaurant
whether you just say sell the meats
don't
frozen meat oh frozen meats you could
sell the mini restaurants
not just one okay
look good this is like bright you know
the bread fluffs up and it gets you know
it's fluffy
oh like a bakery
that name is money bro yeah that name is
money
i could go you know there's a few
different keys yeah
i'm definitely going to fluffy for some
sweet [ __ ] there you go
that was a commercial right there dude
[ __ ] fluffy
something sweet yeah from the hangover
whether or not yeah from the hive we got
a little fluffy
so uh either a uh a bakery
or like a we call it like a fluff and
fold you know they do the laundry and
stuff because it's the word fluffs in it
fluff and feed
all that type of [ __ ] i like it i like
it
so the the transition from going to a
com from uh
a stand-up to uh you know into hollywood
man
how has that transition started you
always picture yourself like doing
voiceovers and uh and acting and
things of that nature um i think in the
beginning
it was one of those you're
pre-programmed as a as a comic
you're pre-programmed for certain goals
for example every comic back in the day
always wanted to have the
tonight show episode they wanted to have
the hbo special
not a netflix special because there was
no netflix not showtime or anything they
wanted the hbo special and then they
wanted the sitcom
once they got to the sitcom level then
they could build a fan base from that
that everybody you know so when they go
on the road they could sell tickets that
was always the pre-programmed goal you
got to do this to do this do this
and then once you're done with tv then
you could try to make that transition to
film
so everything was looked at as a
stepping stone with stand-up being the
first step
yeah so like with with me uh
you know in place i love being on stage
that was my number one love
uh my manager i took on a manager
because they got a lot of work you gotta
love it
you gotta love somebody they gotta pull
you off yeah
you know but okay all right all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna ask you
this question mike
but you know there comes a time like
even you as an athlete when you're
boxing
where you do this you've been doing you
know that's for so long
that it's almost like you start to hate
it or you love it so much that you hate
it
you know what i'm saying do you lose do
you lose love out of something
comedy and boxing boxing i understand it
comes a certain time that you can't do
it
at the level that you really want to do
it and that's the top level
this acting game is immortal it keeps
you living forever
imagine you know you know what it's like
to have a week on broadway or something
like that a big
theater or something you can't imagine
anything better if you're one of those
guys that like attention and like
seeing yourself on television and you
know and i don't know and i'd be saying
wow i don't even like guys like that but
that's the kind of guy i
am um you'd be surprised when i say
somebody put a camera in my face
you know he'd be surprised it's just a
drug
i'm i'm [ __ ] up i'm sorry i grew up in
the 90s i know what you said on camera
uh you put a camera you know what i've
always wanted to know when you put a
camera in my face and i will say
anything there is no shame i don't know
why i'm like that i hate being there
that's the part
oh my god you put a camera in my
face i just turned to somebody i don't
even know
i always used to wonder like what is he
what he that's what he's saying on
camera i wonder what he says to the
fighters in the ring
when you're hitting these guys you know
i'm sure you're not just quiet like
oh you know pow pow no you gotta be
talking about oh
god yes i'm a pig you ever tell anybody
you know like
as soon as i beat you i'm gonna go to
sizzler or something something just
laughing
man it's just basic you know it's really
nasty stuff it's stupid [ __ ]
i'm a nut oh god please forgive me
i imagine i imagine how fun it is uh
because you know mike has his cartoon
but imagine how fun it's been to do all
these like
sequels of the ice age uh scooby-doo
space jam you're gonna be part of this
new movie with uh
with lebron james and space channel yeah
i know i'm very excited to do the
imagine that yeah that's gonna be
forever it's just gonna be forever i
think i'll never forget you
remember the first one bugs bunny mm-hmm
and more yeah see you remember with
jordan
and then we remember it with fluffy yeah
so fluffy gets to play speedy gonzales
in this one oh
damn by the time a mexican place
and he shoots the cat
hello paul damn yeah you know paul
rodriguez uh
yeah are you good friends with paul
rodriguez i know who paul rodriguez
is slowpoke slowpoke is a speedy
gonzalez's
[Laughter]
slow pokes like that uh that ghetto
cousin we all have yeah kind of you know
you only invite them when you can watch
them at all times yeah
are they gonna have him in the movie too
slow no no there's no slow poke in the
movie
i think that was the character that
people were kind of thinking that speedy
gonzalez was
yeah and why they tried to cancel them
slowpoke beautiful
how's it been how's it been with
colewood how's it have you been doing
uh how's it been man i imagine did you
guys go online too like
like the rest of the world with stand-up
and things like that
uh as soon as covet hit i i knew this
wasn't going to be a two-week thing i i
just already knew in my gut no
there's no way this is two weeks i'd say
the first month i was super
you know bummed out and depressed that i
you know i'm on stage in front of people
every single night and all of a sudden
i'm in my room and i'm it's
you know you live alone yeah i live
alone so it's me and my dogs and it's
just like
yeah we're not going anywhere today
either you know what i practice on my
wife you know i make up some story and
told my wife some [ __ ] and i think what
you mean her
fighting but i'm not really mad but i
made this fight look but like i'm going
through this play
you're [ __ ] around on me i'm just
[ __ ] my wife he's driving her nuts
i'm listening it's like to drive my
wife's nuts
i'm really just practicing yeah i was
having fun
yeah driving my wife nuts
just mirrored you guys hear someone
cleaning right next door here
oh okay i'm like wow
what are they doing over there
i know what you put in that mic but yeah
it keeps telling that you start hearing
things
but when when covert hit man i i
basically uh i had to find other things
that i was good at you know i had to
work on other skills in order to you
know
pass the time you can't spend time in
front of people so i started
you know messing around making i created
a tick tock you know i started playing
videos just trying to stay creative in
some way
you know working on some potential
scripts i did the voice over for a space
jam
so that was one of the things uh that's
the big one working on so
yeah it's a huge honor huge honor pretty
good warner brothers took a chance uh i
defended the character when they tried
to cancel it
and so there's nothing wrong with peter
gonzalez mexican people loves peter
gonzalez yeah
he's like one of our heroes like you
can't just what his crime is he's fast
you know he talks fast
[Laughter]
be careful mike tyson i am the fastest
mouse in all nato
what was the cat named sucka what's up
sucker [ __ ] cat the captain's already
trying to get him
[ __ ] sucker puss
yeah that should be a fighter in the
next tyson's punch-out
face that just sounds evil mike
he created a new stripper name
[Laughter]
when you think about it right cartoons
when i used to watch it they're not for
[ __ ] kids i didn't understand that
cartoon was too
complex bugs bunny the woodpecker and
speedy gonzalez
when i got older i understood what's
your what's your favorite piece up to
this uh up to this date
gabby you've done some pretty cool you
know stuff in your in your career man
what do you think is like your your top
gabby's piece man that you
that you're gone she says like hey man
this is this is my best explanation
personally that must be a personal best
like you feeling your heart you say this
is my best
um you know it's i think that whatever
you've done
for me anyways is the last thing that i
did because it's just like the progress
the growth
you know like the each one of the
specials each thing that i did was
uh something that helped grow into that
next
spot so i mean it's like you know every
time you do something you got to make it
a little bit better than the last time
otherwise you know you become somebody's
somebody's gonna pass you up
yeah so it's almost like you have to
constantly be competing
because you're right it's like that in
the game you know what i'm saying
there's
there's a there's a champion out there
another champion that's why nobody's
greater
than the sport of boxing that's where
there's nobody greater than this than
the you know then the event of stand-up
you know what i'm saying because people
will always trickle and
you know what i'm saying the greatest of
all time is always you know the one
that's
straight behind you by a little bit and
if you don't move
you're going to get ran over right the
greatest of all times
never forget this could handle
disappointments
he never gets discouraged no matter what
that's that's what this is all about
being being challenged
by the by the universe how bad you
really want how much you really believe
in it
how do you answer that i don't know man
i was like oh this is a good one
i can see me trying to formulate
something that's deep but you know you
feel special you know i don't mean
you guys know you you're destined for
something not like you feel better than
anybody else you just know that you're
destined for something don't you don't
you feel that way
i think that i was definitely put here
to put smiles on faces absolutely i
think that was that was my gift and
that's what i wanted
there's no accident no no you know god
don't make mistakes
we're all here for for whatever we're
doing yeah that's why i
try to keep the shows as friendly as i
can which is why i think your 10 year
old son could watch the show
you know there's so many different
things that i've
worked on but i always try to keep a
certain you know like i don't like uh
talking about religion in my show i
don't like talking about sports in my
shows i don't like talking about you
know
politics because they're divisive they
cause
people to yeah so it's i'd rather keep
the shows friendly talk about friends
family fun
hangouts i'm gonna talk about this at
some point in my life
mike got me two eyes for this my god
behind i started talking about the
universe the couch opened up man that's
there was a
when did where'd the frog come from i
just don't notice the frog i was like
holy [ __ ]
it's happening we gotta smoke that guy
he smokes with us
the toad yeah that's the toe that's a
psychedelic man i love the psychedelics
does that does that frog have a name
mike i feel like that frog lives on this
set
that's hermit that's herman okay yeah so
you have
your kermit kermit kermit okay
kermit like kermit better you can hear
the next special coming up or is it is
it coming up is gonna be coming up on
netflix uh here pretty soon
yeah how did you feel when you heard you
had a you know a gig they want you to do
a next week
oh you know what anytime you know you
got some work coming up you're always
excited you're looking forward to it
when they call it a special it
definitely is a special you feel
there's there's more to that specific
thing you're doing than any other night
when you're doing
your shows is you know that's special
henry i could
um i could be an audience i could and i
could um entertain one person
and i could entertain 10 000. if one
person's looking at me i entertain them
yeah there's a buck you know it's just i
don't know why i'm gonna like that
so is it kermit or hermit kermit okay
just me i'm high
amen all right hermit a little delayed
everything's gonna start talking right
now kermit yeah
yeah man i'm uh uh the last comic
standing dude
talk about a little bit about that oh
man that was a long time ago
yeah i got kicked off the show for
having a blackberry that's how long ago
it was a blackberry
remember the blackberry phone right you
weren't supposed to have that
uh when you're on the last comic
standing and you know you're competing
against each other and they're afraid
that if you have a cell phone that
they're gonna they're gonna send you
they're gonna send you
outside jokes to help you get to the
next round and you know i'm like oh so
you got kicked out for
you know i mean quasi cheating huh i
wasn't cheating
i was just i had a new girlfriend at the
time and you know you're going to put me
in a hotel for a week and i just hooked
up with this new girl and i'm like
no so i wanted to keep tabs so i snuck
in my phone so i could stay in touch
with her you're a bad
kid man that wasn't a bad kid and i just
didn't think i didn't do anything i just
didn't see you i took myself
on my cell phone on the show with me and
that's that was that
yeah i get kicked off the show yeah and
because i got kicked off the show
you know i didn't go down the route of
whatever they wanted me to do
i i broke off and i was able to do my
own thing so it's almost like because
you became a rebel it was it was able to
spark up your
uh you know your career i mean it's been
a while i don't
did you watch the last uh was it like
that imagine
you know sometimes when somebody when
something dramatic happens on a on a tv
show
it's like when the person breaks off and
if they're able to make it you know it's
because they're
you know you're somewhat known as a
rebel you know what i'm saying i think
everybody's
not saying that you're a rebel but you
know what i'm saying this is just
because it's a nice guy though
they had a nice sky reputation but but
rebel rebel i think everybody has to
have
a rebel in them in order to to advance
to get better to grow
as as whether it's a in your career or
in your life you always have to do
something a little bit different a
little bit uncomfortable
a little bit outside the box in order to
get to where you want to be
you know so everybody has to ah man just
you know sometimes you got to take
control of your own
if you want to get there otherwise
you're just going to continue to do the
same
the same thing day after day so do you
think being kicked off
from that show you think that led more
to your uh to your destiny
yes because then i had to fight to prove
that it wasn't a mistake
i needed to show like to myself more
than anyone
that man this is just a uh you know a
drop in the bucket of disappointments
along the way there's going to be many
more coming
i just got to get through this one and
get on to the next thing you know so it
just
it made me want to go out and just work
more do more shows
get more get in front of as many people
as possible what was your
uh breakthrough mike what do you think
it was for you or something that just
like
you know that triggered i don't know
what i'm fighting
yeah from the amateurs from when you
first started the amateurs and then
going to professional because they're
just swimming best that ever happened to
me i lost my first amateur fight when i
was around
16 years old i fought a guy 25
and um 25 years old yeah but they had
you in open right away
yeah and i was um it's ridiculous man
it was a close fight but i fought real
hard the guy was smart he was a little
bit more experienced than i was
but that loss helped me learn a lot yeah
i'm so happy i had that i wouldn't have
never learned so that was your very
first uh else i learned later in life so
that's my first loss in amateur everest
your first time
ever competing down i did not know that
it was in boston he was a local boy
and it was packed around i don't know
what 15 20 000 people we were fighting
amateurs and then it was new york
against massachusetts
it was packed so you still remember that
to this day
never forget it 40 yeah
and they'll forget it yeah 40 years
later you're still uh
still kind of yeah that's awesome man
you never forget your fights
yeah your disappointments yeah that made
you
you know you always have to be careful
listen just like in
being an entertainer whatever you do
best in life to entertain
your job you got to be careful how you
live your life
i mean live your workplace like my fight
you always have to be careful how you
fight your fight because the way you
fight to fight to be the way you live
your life
and we all live in life by the way we do
our job
and we got extreme jobs even comedian
has an extreme job
really extreme brain constantly working
that's not really [ __ ] normal
we didn't have to rest and then anytime
you're out in public
people coming up to you and you got to
always wonder how are they going to
approach you
are they going to be nice are they going
to be rude are they going to be loud
yeah
you know and so you got to prepare
yourself and sometimes it's not just one
person sometimes
sometimes we take people wrong they like
you but they're not warm
exactly and they feel entitled to your
attention well as my wife always says
they feel like they own you in new york
you know but that is true people
especially of your race they feel like
they own you they come from your
neighborhood or something
that's just how it is you know you
always owe something to someone
you're always walking around like that
like yeah because in reality we do
everybody owes everybody everybody those
guards to give us breath
we owe each other to learn from one
another
you know i mean even our enemies could
teach us
about ourselves this is one big school
the world is just one big school and
we're students
you have kids gabriel you have uh you
have a family wife
uh no wife i have a son uh his
well people already know his name i
promise him i stopped talking about him
on tv
this isn't technically tv though right
frankie yeah yeah
frankie and big time television frankly
mike tyson just said your name frankie
glacious
uh he kept his original factory settings
i can't say his last name oh frank are
you so lucky
yeah so you you choose they know who you
are frank they know
if they know who that is you can't hide
that
yeah it's like uh do you wish to keep
that private because of kind of what you
would you you know
obviously being famous well you know i
think we signed up for the attention and
the spotlight
our families don't always do
yeah uh family friends and stuff like
that they're they didn't sign up for
that they want to just be with the
you know the person not the the thing
that everybody sees
and so yeah you know they don't want to
deal with that sometimes they're good
about it but sometimes they don't want
to do that
sometimes your kids be looking at me you
want this dad this is what you want
and one of my friends look at me you
know he's like i want to walk with my
kids and
whereby the um the basic people started
coming in and
i see my kids walking away from they
feel nervous yeah they walk away from me
they're on the outskirts of everything
like hey where are you going
i'm by myself with the crowd oh they
don't want to be a part of
none of that they love you but they
don't they don't love no
attention that that they don't want to
be a part of none of that stuff
so that's why yeah i try to keep the
private they don't want their business
out there i mean
damn yeah people people forget about
that mike
you know i i think of you you get
selfish sometimes and we want to think
it's all about us but next thing no it's
pushing your children away from you
oh god my children just started thinking
i'm cool again
you know oh yeah it's got back and you
know me in that good graces
magic mike too are you are you are you
uh i was like well you uh
that was an uncomfortable segue nah that
was good
i'm good with my mic's over here like
i'm good with my kids and their magic
mic
[Laughter]
yeah and i was in that tell me about
that i wasn't that i didn't get naked
i didn't get naked none of this
i was the only actor on the set of magic
mike who was allowed to go to craft
service tell me about did you
dance yeah those guys couldn't eat man
they didn't have me dancing
i i i did the car dance i did this one
you know when you're just in the car
they give you money they gave me a lot
of money i was very happy the movie was
a hit it had a sequel and so i got i got
to be in two movies
awesome oh dude that's cool man i
imagine
that actually i remember that movie was
a hitman every every girl i was talking
about what's funny though when people
recognize me
from that movie and then they tell their
friends and they're like
he was in magic mike and then they look
at me like what happened
you know was it cgi like no i wasn't
no i was in it but i wasn't in you know
i didn't
but yeah it was good times yeah man
speaking about celebrity boxing mike
what'd you uh what'd you think of uh
man i want to talk to you about that i
don't know i think floyd did good but he
needs to um
the guy was big you know even though he
was hurting the guy
the guy was big and normally if a guy
was his weight he wouldn't really hit
floyd that hard floyd he would take the
shot
but that guy hit him so that's like a
small heavyweight 190 pounds the floyd's
like 150 something
that's a 30 pound difference that had a
lot to do with it i didn't know
the the weight was such a difference
do you do you think that uh do you think
that that health box and obviously
flo would beat him by points but it's
almost like because he didn't he didn't
he didn't put it on him or didn't hurt
him it's
what else listen he did he maybe um
he came out of she maybe then prepared
properly maybe he didn't spawn with a
heavyweight
because that's what that guy was a small
heavyweight yeah
yeah i had no point though did i ever
feel like it was
uh going bad for floyd i just felt like
you know he just wants to carry it
no i don't think he carried anybody the
guy who made him complicated
guy was awkward and stuff and he didn't
fight in a few years
he was using his length and then he was
clenching it he was clenching him with
piss and slowly
yeah and then dude you don't have that
type of stamina like people people don't
recognize that boxing pressure
boxing pressure from the pure sport of
boxing you guys pressure is scary and
it's different
you know what i'm saying but if somebody
just press anyways what i'm saying is
jake paul is able to
withstand at least eight rounds yeah
that shit's hard mike
oh no doubt about it listen that's why i
i can never say nothing negative about
floyd because this [ __ ] is not easy you
know that
you know this fighting [ __ ] your mind
going there you got it all together and
[ __ ] you start going wrong man
it's it's a hard business it's so
psychological
people think it's physical so
psychological
do you think do you think that's still
hot boxing boxing's gonna do what it's
gonna do
you know i don't think it hurt boxing
you know people have to look and say
floyd is 44 this is a young guy he's 30
pounds heavier
he's younger you could um
you could expect um a difficult fight
you know i thought i just believed floyd
would have had um
because he's very intelligent i thought
that he would arrange this different at
least
10 pounds different you know instead of
30.
you know what the [ __ ] or maybe for the
the brother's lighter
right yeah but yeah brother yeah jake
pause gonna be fine
do you keep up with uh mixed martial
arts gabriel uh
boxing or anything i'm definitely boxing
uh are you gonna referee that fight
for uh chavez uh senior oh that is so
awesome right
i would definitely do that how'd you how
did you hear about that
oh you know yeah yeah because i followed
boxing a little bit
yeah no i and every chance i get for any
any major fight we always get together i
always see
the latest fighters all right now i
think it's the rand james go fight
champions
i think camacho come on it's either
camacho or
not no he's gonna fight camacho junior
right yeah
that's gonna be so [ __ ] crazy right
yeah that's
yeah have you have you refereed a fight
before um
in ufc ufc for that ufc but every may
fight in britain
in prison and great britain oh in great
britain
didn't you rap a fight at wrestlemania
yeah the house oh
i had to have fun with that i love
wrestling
you know i love about also you're a big
guy you're you're a big uh
wwe fans old school wwe when it was wwf
you know and then now it's you know they
got they got a couple companies yeah you
got some competition there
who's who's who are some of your your
greats men in the wwe
oh man uh you know original was of
course hulk hogan for me
uh stone cold steve austin loves stone
cold mm-hmm i haven't
i've fought him before yeah yeah
yeah you have yeah that's right yeah you
went up against stone cold on
yeah that's right i see my favorite with
bruno san martino he goes
like in the 70s and the early 80s
he used to work out with uh
schwarzenegger they would work out
together
bruno san martin on arnold
schwarzenegger would work out oh yeah
i'd always see those old school black
and whites
oh i was the man yeah i tried it
once on a count you know for a shoot and
the one me falling off the ring just to
get on the floor
hurt and i'm like there's no way i could
handle being a professional wrestler
real quick you got to see this man mike
just showed us he did sometimes
i think knew jack was insane there's a
reason why the oh dear something
something crazy look at this guy look at
this [ __ ]
he's the most extreme wrestler i've ever
seen i've never seen
him like he cut his forehead and stuff
look at his forehead
did i never even oh this is a sandman
right there and sandman's one of the
most hardcore wrestlers ever yeah
oh so these dudes oh these are kamikazes
almost though
definitely new jack actually stabbed the
guy
in the ring yeah you know somewhere
the guy did something he did something
like real uh in the corner like i think
he punched his nose or something and
then new jacks
stabbed the guy in the ring he had a
taser he tased him with an actual taser
took into the ring
so he tased him and then oh
yeah call the cops god lee
[Laughter]
i love that new jack was so unapologetic
too he said it right there
i wanted him to hit the floor it was
like whoa oh the dudes
the dude died no no no he didn't die
from that
he didn't know yeah i really got him
something else i was like
years later that other wrestler yeah
yeah you think you would have got
you know gotten into wrestling if if you
wouldn't have done it oh he's definitely
wrestling yeah i used to love wrestling
i was a kid before even though the
boxing bad
and you got machu man or do you got the
whole the whole commanding
match i was gonna do stone cold uh
talking to tyson
man it's about damn time you had me on
your show
and a smoke at the fat mexican to get
the voice in here
i was wondering um
i cannot believe i'm hanging out with
mike tyson
i was trying to make a flinch he don't
flinch people he don't flinch
too high to flinch this damn high
deflection you know what i'm doing
henry yeah yeah a big fan of boxing big
fan of wrestling
mma every time every time dana white
shows up on my in my feed because i
follow dana white i'm just like
what's gonna happen today you know he's
so just
out there best job in the world bad
promote yeah
yeah promoting the fights good job but
yeah he's always
and you know what i'm saying he's you
know always got something to say
yeah okay you have to fight no oscar
wants to fight him yeah
oscar de la hoya oscar wants to fight
dana white oscar would put it on him
dude
you know he's different there's levels
yeah because they want to they want to
make oscar de la versus uh
gsp but oscar de la would hurt gsp too
white didn't want to let it happen yeah
yeah don't do that
yeah you have a different kind of
fighting for your punch and [ __ ]
i think a punch yeah and oscar's a
fighter bro like he's into being the
fight
he's not mayweather he's gonna be all
defensive this is good this dude's
coming at you to kill you dude
yeah he's gonna [ __ ] you up even that
yeah yeah gabriel what's what's next man
what does this
year 2021 bring bring to you hopefully a
lot of work and uh
health prosperity thank you mike uh you
know
i'm just having an awesome time
can i fangirl for just a second go for
it just i i
man i brought pictures i just want to
make sure you sign my picture so i can
put you on my wall i got you mcmahon
you're wearing a degeneration x shirt oh
back in the day yeah
i was the wrestling [ __ ] yeah sorry i
went to the hall of fame no that's
an excellent to the hall of fame yeah
for sure man what are some of the
greatest memories you have of
of mike you know what uh growing up you
know we'd always look forward to those
uh it was either hbo or like a tvko
pay-per-view
and it was you know it was it was back
and forth it was chavez watching a
chavez fight
watching the tyson fight so that before
as soon as mike's fight starts don't
leave the couch
then i was telling wait to the third
round and nine out of 10 times there was
no third round
yeah like you would have missed it
because one time i almost did miss the
fight because i was getting up
and my my brother-in-law pulls me back
he's like
the puerto rican dude love you don't big
camacho fan but he pulled me back and
he's like watch
i don't know i forgot who he was i was
probably what
13 at the time yeah and all your all
your fights were just
you know that's my childhood yeah and
that was my childhood it was you know
again
you know he said no camacho when he was
like he was insane he was beautiful man
he talked a lot of [ __ ]
yeah i saw his uh his show on uh
documentaries documenting on showtime
yeah camacho it was that one fight that
changed everything where he used to be a
fighter
and he started kind of playing more
defense because he had one fight that
really uh
you know kind of brought him back to
reality so he kind of started
shining away from the person he used to
be and then he kind of started losing a
little bit
got into drugs just that whole nine but
he had a lot of love for his mom and
just the way he was
um you know murdered man if you would
say in
puerto rico it's our culture we grew up
around people like that
you know we could always get caught up
into our past
yeah you know this stuff is not easy
tell them this stuff but you know the
stuff is not easy
yeah did they ever catch the person that
did i want to say that
they they had they said they had clues
they knew that they couldn't
prosecute or something you know mike
no but they had clues the show
said the same thing at the conclusion
yeah some of the other fi some of the
other fighters like uh
johnny tapia who's another one
that's who i was my error we was in the
amateurs again oh yeah
yeah i think it was crazy on my did you
ever party with him
we hung out he was just you know he was
wild but he was a good person
yeah he was just one of those brothers
that was abused as a kid
had a chip on his shoulder he was a
little guy but he was the tough mean
[ __ ]
you know he would fight anybody who was
who were some of the closest mikes who
were some of the closest uh
boxing friends that won world titles
that that we
probably know that you're closest to
chavez trinidad
trinidad i feel like that too yeah he
used to be promoted
with us did you ever go out to puerto
rico with him
yeah yeah how was that dude he was the
king out there
yeah how did how did the puerto rican
people receive you down there they're
good
i've been there a couple of times yeah
and um i've been uh cooler kind of
visited
chavez yeah you went to kuliakan yeah
that was pretty interesting wow
that was pretty interesting dude as far
as i could say you're probably you
probably went to a party and kicked it
with the
el chapo who knows man oh man
who knows yeah that's imagine
interesting people
every time somebody goes to in my family
i'm like why
what's going on we're coming we're
coming back with a bunch of bags
okay i'm gonna go yeah they saw really
good masapanis over there we're just
gonna go get
some tacos and call it a day man well
gabriel man what what advice you got for
him
mike man he's uh no listen he's just
he's the humble brother you know he's
just staying the same path the
determination to drive the will to want
to do this stuff
you know but you have to want it more
than anybody else want it
yes yes i learned this
you know it's my since i've been
interested in some old black and white
movie
weston to say i want to be up more than
anybody want me to be down
they have to look at life like that and
it happened that way whatever you say
you are is what you are
if you think if you say you're a stupid
fool that's what you are you say i'm a
great genius
that's what you are whatever you say
about yourself
or whatever you think is right to
each perspective up or down yeah i've
definitely said both to myself
you're the best you're the worst yeah
greatest advice you only say that you
only say the worst
to be able to say you're the best and
bounce back from it yeah that's why you
say i'm the worst
then i say no i'm the best my mind plays
tricks our mind is not our friend
you know we have to have our mind in
check we have to control it
because we don't control that tell us
some crazy [ __ ]
i don't know why it's like that though
yeah gabriel what uh what message man do
you have for all your fans out today
they did they they all go
so you got which one you got by me check
on dan dan you good
all right
dan's like fluffy had no idea what was
going to happen to him today
he had no idea he doesn't come here and
just talk about the mouse and the movie
oh you have a lot of people watching
you right now it got really deep i'm
still wondering how i'm going to get
home
and if farmer boys are still yeah people
to drive
uh yeah yeah yeah we could find that uh
as far as a message
or uh what was
how do you feel your gratitude about
being who you are it's my
son loving you people kids loving you
do you feel some responsibility to live
up to for that
yes they have to a responsibility that's
why you know
i'm hesitant to do something like you
know smoke weed
you know in public because people have a
certain
image uh or a certain way that they see
what i do and because people you know
have kids that want to come out
they're like hey you know can you set
somewhat of a good example
you know and so it is uh very
challenging for me to put myself in
certain situations as cool and as fun as
it is
you know i take a risk by doing that i
take a risk that people are going to be
like
you know what that's not what i signed
up for that's not what i thought look
he's doing
how could he make decisions and choices
like that and so that is hard because
you know when you put yourself in a
situation
a certain box people have those
expectations
that's why i filed all of a sudden
started talking about politics people
would
lose half you know so there's a certain
image and a certain thing that
you belong on children's child child and
tv you can't say it i can't do it mike
[Laughter]
the choice awards for kids and all that
stuff you need to be you need to have
the children crowd
you can never lose with the kids you can
never lose
you got that temperament too they love
you my son love you think though
all you do sit down watch youtube and
all that stuff he loves you
thank you but to your point about
responsibility that's why it is hard
sometimes because
people have certain levels of what
should be the responsibility
yeah you know as artists i think people
hold us to a different place where it's
like oh yeah
i would look at you totally different if
you was a
like a cursor or something like that i
would just look at you totally different
not good at barriers no boom this is who
he is and stuff
just the fact that he doesn't my kid
just loves them and my kids are great
kids
i know you have good energy out there
it's like you have to
you have to cater to the masses and the
masses is the
majority and the majority in this
situation are kids
there's more kids than adults in this
world
right this is this is a um this is a pgg
version of our interviews
[Laughter]
and you know it's like people forget you
know i'm a regular person i do
cuss i do have habits i do
you know uh say random things from time
to time that might not go over well
on stage so what you deliver and you
know in public versus what you get
backed up but what you deliver is what
you get back
you gotta love i love you that's why my
kids love you i mean he wouldn't come so
bad there but he had to go on the field
trip today
they couldn't be here it couldn't be
that's what's up here
any you want to close it out for us man
um closing thoughts
be careful with your life's choices this
is going to be the soundbite they'll
play like 30 years from now or 20 years
from now the day that i die look
up right here tell us about life choices
no
i think mike what you said is true what
you put out is what you get back
exactly uh put out good energy and good
energy will come back to you and if
you're an ass
expect [ __ ] things to happen to you
what what if you want to ask would you
give if you oh man
that's yeah
[Laughter]
i saw the inner comic cave made me mad i
don't know what you i hope you're
crossing with that joy mike
no way jose with some um
viagra right oh my god i laced it with
viagra
well there you have it guys you guys
just watched the episode of hop boxing
with mike tyson i am your co-host a.k.a
iglesias you got it the gleason the
glace
the leafcleaf and that's it we gleafy
you